being a hero it's not about Glory
it's about sacrifice
welcome to Good olken University
we've trained the best and brightest
young Heroes since 1965.
godolken is a safe space for you to
thrive
Marie Moreau you could be the first top
ranked freshman in history I think you
meant to say first black woman in seven
but you have a Target on your back
a few of us are going off campus let's
have a good time
I'm still drunk from last night perfect
just take a sip say turbo Rush cares
hangovers I wouldn't pour this on my
giving cured cancer
there are dangerous evil people at that
school
[Music]
everything is
I exploded his tag team explosion
freshman class is savages here